rece davis back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Reese I'm doing great
rich how are you how's your bracket
screwed up but your Wolverines are still
standing tall for me so that's about it
how far do you have Helen I have him
going to the final four and I had
Villanova and Arizona playing for the
championship so that's that's not good
and I had Michigan State in the Final
Four as well mm-hm and this coming after
because I mean I've got great respect
for Izzo and every like that but every
year I get seduced and I end up taking
them to the Final Four and before the
brackets came out I said no matter what
I'm not picking Michigan State go to the
Final Four and then I did I don't know
why hey look you've got some history
with the state of Michigan spent some
some time in Flint back in the day I
mean is those taking a beating right now
based on that do you think it's deserved
I mean I'm assuming you're just talking
basketball yes yes yes Syracuse yeah no
they mean they didn't play well and
there's enough blame to go around for
everybody I don't think it means he's
diminished as a coach Kerr didn't have a
good game plan I mean they just didn't
that they couldn't I guess what I'm
saying is it could have been their game
plan just standing around and launch
three they didn't get enough movement
they didn't get into the middle of the
zone but it's tough to do against
Syracuse but they should have their
they're the better team Michigan State's
a better team than Syracuse and it's one
it's a loss that shouldn't have happened
and when that happens at a program like
that you're going to get beat up a
little bit you probably deserve a couple
punches but not you know not anything
over the top it doesn't mean he's lost
his touch or you know he's got a great
coach in the tournament anymore which I
you know heard somebody throwing out of
earlier today well I think that's silly
but in that particular game they didn't
play or coach well mmm and surcease can
just make you look awful yep
I mean that two-three zone how do you
and and now here comes Duke with a
similar defensive scheme how do you
think that's gonna be playing out coming
in I think it I think Duke playing so
much zone this year will actually help
them and they've got a number of guys
that can make plays in the middle of it
Wendell Carter and Marvin Bagley are you
know handful going high-low you got
shoot
I think Duke will handle them now
Syracuse knows how to play them but I
think the reverse of that is true also
so I I think Duke will move on I think
Syracuse is a magical run will come to
an end now and let's get into the UMBC
of it all man that was incredible and
again I you know a and I say that just
fully knowing that it the the loss for
anybody that I know with Virginia I know
some friends I texted them I saw Chris
long with about five minutes to go tweet
out goodbye Twitter has he tweeted since
then Brockman at all has he I don't
think that could that possibly be Joel
at Joel nine one Chris Long's farewell
to to Twitter I mean that was oh no he
did tweet last night another one seed
went down I'm back on this website
really was that's that's why we watch
this tournament Reese right yes
typically what happens though is the
elation that you feel at watching
history in the first round then
absolutely ruins the next couple of
rounds you know I don't know that that
was the case in this particular instance
but I can't fathom how that happened one
of the things I tweeted out as I was
watching that game is I can't explain
this and I don't want to because that's
part of that's part of the magic that
this team lost by 40 points to Albany
they lost by you know 25 at home to
Vermont they had no business beating
Virginia and yet they did and one of the
reasons we enjoy this tournament rich is
because of the human element as as it
became more and more serious you could
see the weight of the world falling on
Virginia's shoulders and the panic
setting in and it's not like that you
enjoy seeing that but it's dramatic and
and you see the confidence rising on the
other side and it's why it's compelling
to people who you know who are big
basketball fans and some who are just
casual sports fans you can still enjoy
the human drama element and then you
know Kansas State avoided being the
first nine seed to lose to
sixteen and they're part of our poll
question Brockman ask it of rece Davis
please go for it which cinderella has
the best chance to advance race the two
sevens Texas A&M Nevada the two nines
Kansas State Florida State or the two
11s Syracuse Loyola Chicago I'm gonna go
with A&M because A&M is a top three or
four line talent team but they certainly
are deserving of where they were seeded
based on the way they played this year
but talent wise they're elite so I would
I would go with with the sevens just
because of A&M so those who might not be
familiar with the Aggies season why were
they seeded so low well they one thing
they got to a pretty good start they
hammered West Virginia I think that a
game was played in Germany early and
kind of played well in the
non-conference and for some inexplicable
reason I they did have some suspension
that some injury they started conference
play in the SEC Oh and five I think and
sort of stumbled around and then kind of
got it back together later in the season
put together a little little surge in
February but they've got explosive
athletes they've got shooters I think
everybody just watch the tournament have
seen you know Williams have his head fly
up around the top of the square and you
know they they overpowered North
Carolina last night so they were seated
lower largely because they didn't
perform well in the middle of the season
early part of SEC play and really I
would say into February a little bit
when they started playing a little bit
better and and then and then you know
they probably hurt themselves too
because they lost early in the SEC
Tournament on Colin sextants buzzer
beater so you know they they've gone it
they've been up and down for sure but
they played really well in the
n-c-double-a Turner so if I gave you
rece Davis an opportunity to reach OU's
right now you know I think there is some
some way that you could probably go on
espn.com and choose a bracket from 16 on
through right now I would go would to be
honest either I would go Duke versus
Kentucky right now what would you say
Reese I'm gonna I'm gonna stick with
Villanova rich I mean I would still I
would still have Villanova and Michigan
in the Final Four but I I would
with you that that I would have Kentucky
and Duke going to Final Four - mm-hmm
because you take a look at it and again
I'm loath to say this because we've seen
so many of these upsets I mean can't I
can there's never been a five seed go to
a regional final packing only their home
uniforms that's never happened before
yeah you know and you know I think Cal
got on our show that night and he was
you know whining and complaining about
yeah but you know doing it and highly
entertaining fashion mean basically
every time we have cow on we wind up
like five six minutes heavy and it's
because you know the producers saying
should we get out of this and I mean
talk about going no no just let him go
he's wildly entertaining on television
yeah but he's also done a really good
job with his team and they've improved
so you know I think it goes to show you
that seeding is important and I do think
that they miss seeded that region but
then as it turns out once the game
started doesn't matter because the whole
bracket got blown up anyway you know so
it was you just have to play the team
that's in front of you but it is good
theater when when Cal starts talking
about making me you know making us fly
to Boise and play on Thursday they
couldn't even let us wait until Friday
and all of that you know it's
entertaining mm-hmm so you still take
Michigan huh I mean I do I'd like them
rich you know the funny thing is I've
liked them all season but when I really
became totally sold on them I called
their game at Purdue and they lost but
that Purdue team was playing great long
winning streak and it took every drop
that Purdue had in a raucous atmosphere
in Mackay to beat Michigan and Michigan
has a lot of tough matchups I think for
other teams their veteran team beelines
a really good tournament coach you know
I think I really love vogner and I do
rock Mon I really think those guys are
terrific players and and a little bit
underrated particularly I'd go rock
mount I think he's underrated as a
player so I was thinking with Michigan I
know they were very fortunate very
fortunate to get past Houston but now
that they did everybody needs one of
those I still think we'll see the
Wolverines in San Antonio yeah okay
before I let you go I'm gonna
I'm gonna go there and there being this
since I'm speaking to the host of game
day of both college basketball and
football just seeing this tournament
Reese why aren't we expanding the
football playoffs could you imagine
could you imagine if it was a three week
for a just like the one that we're about
to witness in college basketball could
you imagine if it was like that for
college football in December all the way
through to mid-january
I think that would be too big rich I
really do and and I know that you and I
don't agree on this I think the number
four is right for the moment I think
there's going to come a time in the next
few years when it's probably going to go
to eight and I think there will need to
be some radical adjustments paid namely
what are you going to do with conference
championship games
I agree with you if you if you've got
rid of them and made it eight teams
first round on campus I would be more I
would be more in for doing it now but
right now I think four is good the flip
side of it is this when you see a team
like and that look I know this is a one
out of a 136 times but you see a team
like Virginia which dominated the
regular season they clearly were the
best and most consistent team in the
regular season and then they they you
know they step in in the empty elevator
shaft and it's done I guess the team
that accomplished nowhere near what they
did in the in the regular season so you
know you put out if you expand the
football playoff I mean I can't imagine
going past eight but if you went past
eight to 16 as I've heard you sir I
understand there's some drama but you
throw out unnecessary landmines out
there for teams that have accomplished a
lot in the regular season
college basketball has a regular season
problem right now in terms of viewership
in terms of interest in terms of
Fannie's in the seats and college
football is starting already even though
it's still wildly popular in ratings
attendance is an issue some places you
diminish the regular season I think you
have to take a really long-term
big-picture view of that before you just
get caught up and wanting to have you
know three exciting weeks or four
exciting week
whatever it might be always a great
chatting with you Rhys look forward to
watching your coverage all the way
through San Antonio thank you buddy you
got it Rhys Davis at ESPN underscore
Reese our ECE Davis the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience